my channel is sponsored by nordpass
which means we will hear more from them
in the middle of the video hello
everyone i'm alan and welcome to my
channel and today i am very excited to
be able to show you guys 15 minutes of
this particular map of death loop thanks
to bethesda for giving me a code i've
been playing the game for about five
hours now and basically i took a bunch
of questions from you guys um and i'm
gonna play through some of the game
while i answer them right now so if you
don't know anything at all about death
loop um comes out september 15
playing this on ps5
and
you basically have to exist in a loop
over and over and over again um you can
experience the same day on repeat
until you are able to kill eight
visionaries these eight people must all
be killed in the same one day
for you to finish the game i assume it
could be more complicated than that but
that's the task that i have set out
right now in my current loop
i have actually killed
two people but it's night time which
means i'm out of time there is no way
that i'm gonna kill the other six and
the thing that really really appeals to
me about this game is trying to figure
out how on earth to kill all eight of
them because there is no way you're
going to do it yourself at least that's
what i'm thinking um this is one very
big puzzle i need to figure out a way to
take out two of them at once to get one
of them to kill another one i can take
this person out though we do this little
scan here tells you oh they look drunk
what boom
this is uh actually one of the
visionary's weapons
um it'll shoot this nice little
gas that'll knock people out
and otherwise the gameplay like
obviously i have this uh ability that is
very much like dishonored right now um
the other one that i have is a link
chain ability
that will link two people together so
whatever happens to this one
will also happen to this one if i do
this
probably a bit of a big range there
should have used a rifle or something
but
you get the idea they both die because
one of them died
and now a bunch of people know that i'm
here
but that's actually not going to be a
problem which is a very interesting
thing about death loop is that the ai
really will let you go away um they're
not going to find me they don't find you
very easily
and
at first i was like wow this game's
really really easy i i feel like i've
taken out or killed every single person
in a level multiple times and you can
just dip kind of slightly out of the way
of the ai they don't have very good
cones of vision so often you can walk up
right next to them and kill them
but
it's actually because that grander
puzzle that we were just talking about
is
very difficult um so the difficulty is
not in you know the individual enemies
in any level it is in the puzzle of how
on earth
i am supposed to actually kill every
single one of these visionaries in a
single playthrough it just seems
very difficult um and also you know
before we get into the questions here
one thing worth pointing out
the gunplay versus dishonored which
obviously everybody knows arcane for
so much better no just out here right
now
but i mean if i want to just jump up
here
find them and scan them so if we do this
it'll give me like a little bit of extra
detail about them about what they have
on them all that stuff i'm just gonna
run away from that
and just mow them all down but yes
that's not the point of the game and i
don't really feel like i can show you
the point of game in gameplay right now
without spoiling the loop which they
really specifically ask me
not to do so i'm not gonna do that ooh
that was quite an explosion
and if i take one of these
i'll get some help back
so if we die
this is the third ability that i wanted
to show you guys here um i just got
reset and i go invisible for a moment
because of uh the main ability that colt
who is our protagonist has he can die
twice in a day and then you will get
reset to a starting point so that you
don't just die once in any given day and
then completely fail
the rest of the mission for the end of
time which would be a huge bummer um i
need to go pick up
what is on my body here we can scan this
person see what they got on them they're
wary thinks today will be uneventful
standard kit well all your friends are
dead so
how'd that work out for you
so see these people are like kind of
tagging me right now they're all very
close to me i'm just gonna do this
and they're all just gonna be gone
um there are hacking abilities as well
if i come up here there'll be a little
turret around here that i could hack
um
and there are a ton of uh
safes for you to crack a load of
codes that will randomize
each time that you need to find to be
able to enter things as an example of
how the codes generally look so you can
just autofill
to open
one of your many doors but uh we're not
going to do that i'm going to stick out
here for you guys right now michael
crystal said in dishonored you could go
through the entire game without being
spotted and with alternative options for
dealing with major opponents without
killing them is it still possible in
death loop
um no you do have to kill in order to
stop the loop you have to kill the eight
visionaries they have to die
um i'm sure there are different ways to
kill them different things that i have
not done yet that's you know again the
puzzle that we're trying to figure out
here is
exactly how to do that i'm just gonna
hack one of these right now
there we go and you can do that and now
it'll shoot anyone that goes past which
is pretty handy benjamin and obviously a
whole bunch of other people asked is it
a lot like dishonest
i mean it's pretty clearly like
dishonored just from what you're looking
at right now i would think um you know
it's i'm gonna jump on this pipe and
then i'm gonna
crawl through a window here or or i'm
gonna use
blink to get on this rooftop so yeah
it's gonna look a lot like dishonored
however tonally
way different this game is super stylish
kind of jazzy in vibe it's it's
very different feel
to dishonored and the gameplay feels
really different too so you have access
to these different levels that are all
mini sandboxes i've explored this one
pretty thoroughly um though
i haven't done it every time of day
there are four different times of day
the maps are all different at different
times of day but the purpose is really
to revisit these little sandboxes over
and over find as much information as you
can
find different tidbits once you have one
piece of information from one level go
to another level and see if that can
connect something there see if you can
find out about a relationship between
two of the visionaries to see if you can
get them together at some point so that
you will be able to figure out the exact
timing needed to murder every single one
of them and i don't know but i sort of
suspect that there will be
an exact order
maybe there'll be multiple but it feels
like you know when i started playing i
was like oh this is gonna require me to
be so specific it feels like you may
have to figure out the perfect order it
is time to talk about nordpass if you
didn't already know nordpass is a
password manager it helps you organize
your passwords and secure notes keeping
them all in a single place an encrypted
password vault with nordpass you can
shop online with ease it remembers all
of your credit card details you can also
share passwords securely no more
password sharing over email messenger
apps or pieces of paper one of my
favorite features because it's something
that i can be very forgetful about is
password health you use password help to
check if your password's a week older
than 90 days or used for several
accounts to make sure that you are
keeping yourself secure across the board
at all times lawn pass also has a data
breach scanner so you can find out if
your online account or credit card
information has been leaked somewhere
and it helps you stay safe online
overall in my opinion and in my
experience nordpast just gives me such a
comforting sense of security and keeps
all of the information that i really
need to be kept secure secure so as part
of the so long summer sale gets 74 off
nordpass at nordpass.com alana plus you
get four additional months for free that
is nordpass.com alana and if you want to
find that link more easily you can also
check it in the top of the description
box now back to the video i'm gonna
stealth fill this person i'll show you
what that looks like
pretty basic stuff and they all
obviously have masks on and they
disappear when they die but uh those
little smoke things they leave behind
other enemies will still come and uh
investigate joel sonic's ask is there a
timer on levels no there is no timer
once you enter a level which i thought
was very interesting i was worried about
that but once you enter a level you can
spend as long in the level as you want
you can do whatever you want investigate
whatever you want
um and i do recommend doing that i would
actually say when you first start
jumping into the game get through the
levels fast to get acquainted with the
mechanics and how everything works but
once you get a little bit further um all
of my weapons right now by the way are i
have them permanently just for context
it's not a roguelike there is a currency
system which i think is pretty neat um
that is actually related to i think we
just passed
so this is residium it'll appear as like
these little kind of rifts in the world
i currently have 2 000
um when you exit any level you will get
a menu where you can choose where to
allocate your residium and say this
weapon that i currently have cost me 8
000 residium using that means that every
time that i die i will spawn with this
gun again and i'm a very big fan of this
gun so you can't keep everything that
you have you have a pretty limited
inventory anyway i think these are all
the weapons at least for now maybe
there'll be some upgrades in the future
that i'm allowed to have you can see the
um i think they're called uh weapon uh
trinkets that i have attached there mine
leads straight to the crack shot um
these are both
very fun guns
but you can keep them but yes the levels
themselves will finish either when you
die or when you choose to leave them the
timer exists in that there are like i
said four times a day and you can only
go to one level each time of day so you
can visit four levels in a day in theory
if i wanted to i could visit this
specific map four times and see how it's
different every single time and i'm sure
there will be people who play it that
way but it's really like coming to this
map figuring out what information it
tells me about what other people are
doing this is gonna be another residium
or residum i guess it's called i just
keep calling it resilient um
finding out where
some of the people you need to find and
kill are at different points in the game
and then going to track them down and
putting all these pieces together and
like i said i played about five hours
and i don't even feel like i'm close i
feel like there is a giant puzzle still
ahead of me but that i'm definitely
getting better that i have some
abilities that i like that i've leveled
up this one actually i killed the same
person twice to get this chain link
ability um so that i could also upgrade
it so i definitely feel like my cult the
character has gotten cooler but um
that's where the timer exists is in
figuring out who is where and why so
there are a lot of questions about open
world and i feel like that answers it
pretty well they are it's not an open
world game there are just these four
sandboxes and again maybe that could end
up being more but as far as i'm aware
only four phoenix [ __ ] asks related
to that does a loot mechanic ever get
repetitive or frustrating i have not
felt that way at all um i've actually
never unintentionally died on a loop i
feel like it'll get frustrating if
in the long run i can't figure out what
i need to do or how to solve this giant
puzzle that's ahead of me but i'm not at
that point yet and i can't show you this
part of the menu but it functions kind
of similar to hitman where you get leads
so as i'm exploring these levels and i'm
finding stuff and i'm looking at pieces
of paper and i'm looking through
terminals i'm like oh this person talks
to this person at this time this
person's doing this i should investigate
this and then you can go and explore
those things so it does feel like i have
a very long list of things that i still
can currently do so at this stage not
frustrating at all i'm just super
curious super excited i'm very very into
this conceptually foxy how an employee
said what are you hoping to improve in
this bill that you're playing for the
final product performance would be my
big thing um i've had the game freeze a
number of times and some pretty bad
frame rate drops and i've had a bug
where i get stuck in the menu um then i
have to hard close the game and open it
up again that's the only thing that i
want them to change um i do feel like
some of the writing
in the game can be a little bit
obnoxious but
it suits the style and it also suits the
era you know it's set in the 60s
people are all about partying in this
universe that's the circumstance that
they're in and the world building
definitely
lends to that there's a really specific
reason why these people are in this loop
and i think the lore is all very cool as
well chris holloway said is it story
based like are the cool mechanics and
gameplay all centered around the story
or the other way around yeah it is super
story based david has his stealth and
actual viable option in the game
absolutely yes um you can definitely
stealth your way through and in some
cases without any spoilers you will have
to or you will fail um certain things or
certain things will be triggered that
will prevent you from learning more
information or getting through to
someone bingo asked how many loop
i think the game uh
you actually can find out like kind of
what loop they're on and how many there
have been um in a way that again i'm
into the story i think is very fun
but i believe
the game will loop for as long as it
needs to until you finish it
you will play the same day um it's not
the same day for you it's the same day
for everyone else
over and over and over again
until you figure out how you're going to
kill all of these eight people
in just
four different times of day
okay so i'm only allowed to show you
guys 15 minutes of gameplay so i thought
that i would uh jump to the start of
this level so this is basically the very
early morning of the same level pulse
bay
um and things do look different um these
texts by the way i don't actually know
who's written them
but they change i think i wrote them
somehow i don't know how i see what i
mean about you know their vision being
pretty poor you can get pretty damn
close to the front of them and still
manage to take them out pretty easily
because that's not the point the
if if they were really hard to kill i
think the game would be very frustrating
to play solid snape said do you feel
like any playstyle is favored over
another for example a certain level is
clearly more designed for itself while
others are designed for combat
no i would say the levels are pretty
similarly designed i mean they look very
different you know they
even at different times of day some of
them can look completely different and
within the levels there are things that
look very different
um but i don't feel like there are
really specifically different
play styles or not in any way that's
super obvious to me
um within
the levels themselves i have to avoid
that because it can make me cough as
well
see
[Music]
get out of here
most of the other questions here i
either don't know the answers to
or uh it's people
just um asking me if it's worth it um
and i always feel like i can't answer
that question like
do i think it's worth it for you to buy
without knowing you as a human i really
don't feel equipped to answer that
question um
i don't know you're tasting games i
don't know what kind of things you like
if you like a puzzle game and you love a
sense of discovery in a video game i
would think that you're going to really
like death loop um i do also feel like
if you didn't like dishonored previously
because
some of the gameplay was off-putting to
you for whatever reason you're not going
to feel that way about death loop it's a
lot sharper it's a lot shootier it's a
lot faster like i said you don't have to
be any winners meticulous with the
stealth
or anything like that
and it is a much flashier more fancy
more stylish game
i think it's very good i
was very excited about it and it has
lived up to my expectations but yeah
that's pretty much it for me today
everyone um that's all i'm allowed to
show you and i feel like a lot of the
questions i got were pretty similar but
if i missed anything that i can answer
you know feel free to ask
uh questions and i will
try to get to them if they're in the
comments but i'm very into this game
very excited about
you know everyone else getting their
hands on it and seeing how people tackle
it and i really do want to urge you
because of how
big this puzzle feels to not spoil it
for yourselves don't look up a
walkthrough don't watch streams try to
avoid all of that stuff it's
a game that you like me are excited
about because it would be so much better
um that is it for me today everyone i
hope you enjoyed this video and i will
see you guys next time bye